the success-oriented pragmatic type
adaptable excelling driven and image
conscious
Jeff you said you had something you
wanted to add well yeah I just wanted to
now that we've
now that we have an actual
like tangible beginnings of a plot
rather than a set of open-ended
possibilities I wanted to
quickly revisit the 36 to see which ones
are jumping out and grabbing me by the
throat
like disaster Revolt is very very
Central daring Enterprise
um Madness
rivalry of Superior and inferior is
really interesting because
it's like this kind of this it's this
robot versus the Sun
and who's the superior who has the upper
hand which is very much a matter of
perception because the son could think
he's way in charge and the robot could
be
working circles around him like have you
know connection to the whole Factory and
everything
but the sun could then Trump that and be
like
you know like who's who's the Superior
in any given situation
and or the perception of who's Superior
the son can think he's Superior when
he's not and the vice versa with the
robot so it's an it's a very active
element in this story and it goes hand
in glove with conflict with a god
ambition
uh Madness
Revolt you can see how some of those
kind of formal molecule that constitute
the core of this story so I just wanted
to do a quick run through and see which
ones are jumping right out at me
and it's interesting here looking back
at an automaton
wants to steal
or wants to stop the theft of
interesting a medicine and a Contagion
there's a death
the innocent will suffer but it means
giving up their dreams see now that has
real traction because if he's going to
become human
and he's actually exhibiting aspects of
being a human now like being Giddy and
having fun you know it's like the gods
becoming mortal he gets to experience
some of
what humans experience
so he doesn't want to give up on that
dream
he's now got more of a dream to give up
on and wish granting is more active here
and treachery and Glory these are like
these are solidifying
so what I would do now would be to take
a look at the Enneagram
which is a personality profiling system
that is a combination of
ancient wisdom about human nature and
cutting-edge psychology
and
what I'm looking at here is a
this comes from a website called the
Enneagram
institute.com and Enneagram is
e-n-n-e-a-g-r-a-m
and it basically says that there's nine
different personality types
um
and each of those types has their own
preferences fears motivations drives
subconscious attitudes relationship to
the world and so on
and so in going through it
I would be
looking at a brief description of all
nine types and seeing if any of them
jump out at us for the only three
characters we actually have at this
point which is the automaton the sun and
the dead father
so type number one is the reformer
the rational idealistic type principled
purposeful self-controlled and
perfectionistic basic fear of being
corrupt evil or defective
and each of the nine types has healthy
aspects average aspects and unhealthy
aspects
so
type one the reformer the rational
idealistic type principled purposeful
self-controlled and perfectionistic
certainly seems like it could possibly
be the robot the thing about this is
they have an extreme sense of justice of
right and wrong
and
they really want to make the rights the
wrongs into rights
but as they get into the average and
unhealthy aspects they become rigid and
um
well let me just read a little bit from
the healthy aspect of a type one
conscientious with strong personal
convictions they have an intense sense
of right and wrong personal religious
and moral values wish to be rational
rational reasonable self-disciplined
mature and moderate
that sounds like Spock
and could be this
AI or whatever it is
in the average aspect
dissatisfied with reality they become
high-minded idealists feeling that it is
up to them to improve everything
Crusaders Advocates critics into causes
and explaining to others how things
ought to be
they can be moralizing scolding abrasive
and indignantly angry and in the
unhealthy aspects they can be highly
dogmatic self-righteous intolerant and
inflexible begin dealing in absolutes
they alone know the truth everyone else
is wrong they're very severe in
judgments
so I could also see the sun being this
character
because the rigid dogmatic aspects can
be like
Hitler going I know best and I am saving
the world for everybody else
even though he's crazy and completely
wrong from his point of view he's doing
an important job
and it also brings up the question of
how does a robot exhibit unhealthy
aspects but we've talked about that with
corrupting the operating system and even
putting some kind of catnip in there or
something
to make this robot giddy where it was
former formerly
you know like data like it doesn't get a
joke or something like that
type 2 the helper the caring
interpersonal type generous
demonstrative people pleasing and
possessive basic fear of being unwanted
Unworthy of being loved the servant is
one of those types
impassion empathic compassionate feeling
for others caring and concerned about
their needs
I'm wondering if that could be the robot
it's not jumping out at me a lot I'm not
sure if a robot would
feel Unworthy of being loved
but it's worth taking a look at for a
minute
type 3 the achiever the success oriented
pragmatic type adaptable excelling
driven and image conscious basic fear of
being worthless basic desire to be
valuable and worthwhile that could be
the sun it totally could be the Sun
um and
the the healthy type three
is self-assured energetic competent with
high self-esteem they believe in
themselves in their own value adaptable
desirable charming and gracious
and even if the Sun is unhealthy he can
exhibit these healthy attributes even if
it's just an act but it can be Charming
lovable High performing
fascinating
um in the average aspect highly
concerned with their performance with
doing their job well constantly driving
self to achieve goals is if self-worth
depended on it terrified of failure
compare yourself with others and search
for status and success
uh become careers social climbers
invested in exclusivity and being the
best become image conscious highly
conceived highly concerned with how they
are perceived
begin to package themselves according to
the expectations of others and what they
need to do to be successful so threes
really care about what they look like to
others and the more unhealthy they get
the more desperate acts they'll do to
keep looking good
so in the unhealthy fearing failure and
humiliation they can be exploitative and
opportunistic Covetous of the success of
others and willing to do whatever it
takes to preserve the illusion of their
superiority devious and deceptive so
their mistakes and wrongdoings will not
be exposed untrustworthy maliciously
betraying or sabotaging people to
triumph over them
so that's an interesting
um
strong possibility for the Sun and they
say that the basic fear really drives
each of these nine types and here the
basic fear for a Type 3 is of being
worthless
so really wants to feel valuable and
worthwhile and is kind of irrationally
desperate to overcome that subconscious
belief that he is worthless and it could
be a she it doesn't have to be a male
the everything's fluid at this point
Type 4 the individual is the sensitive
withdrawn type expressive dramatic
self-absorbed and temperamental basic
fear that they have no Identity or
personal significance basic desire to
find themselves and their significance
so the healthy one is self-aware
introspective on the search for
self-aware of feelings and impulses
sensitive and intuitive average take an
artistic romantic orientation to life
creating beautiful aesthetic
environments heightened reality through
fantasy and they want to sort out their
emotions before they move tackle
anything else unhealthy when dreams fail
become self-inhibiting and angry itself
depressed and alienated from self and
others I'm not sure if that feels like
any of these three
type 5 the investigator the intense
cerebral type perceptive Innovative
secretive and isolated
basic fear being useless helpless or
incapable the basic desire to be capable
and competent and one of the one of the
types is the problem solver
and there's also the iconoclast and it's
possible that both the father and
the
automaton could
share this type
but be slightly different like the
father could be an iconoclast
one who really wants to shake things up
and change things
and the automaton may be more of a
problem solver but maybe becomes an
iconoclass becomes revolutionary
um
the healthy aspect of a five is to
observe everything with extraordinary
perceptiveness and insight most mentally
alert curious searching intelligence
nothing escapes their notice foresight
and prediction able to concentrate
become engrossed in what has caught
their attention
attain skillful Mastery and whatever
excites them excited by knowledge often
become expert in some field Innovative
and inventive producing extremely
valuable original Works highly
independent idiosyncratic and whimsical
at their best they become Visionaries
broadly comprehending the world while
penetrating it profoundly
so this is someone who sees things
sort of differently from other people is
intensely smart
trying to get to the bottom of things
connecting things in unusual ways that
most people don't and can come up with
innovative solutions
and the average aspect can begin
conceptualizing and fine-tuning
everything before acting working things
out of their mind model building getting
ready forever and never leaping into
action is their worst trait
so in the unhealthy become reclusive and
isolated from reality eccentric and
nihilistic highly unstable and fearful
of aggressions
reject and repulse I could see the
father kind of going downhill at the end
and sort of naturally being secretive
especially with a big organization in
industrial Espionage and maybe got
shafted by one of his top people and now
doesn't trust anybody then leans more on
the robot and starts to reprogram the
robot to be more like the one person I
can trust but then the father gets
killed and the Sun starts to reprogram
so it's interesting possibilities
type six the loyalist the committed
security oriented type engaging
responsible anxious and suspicious the
basic fear of being with without support
or Guidance the basic desire to have
security and support
now that's possibly interesting for the
robot because the basic fear of being
without support or guidance
that
we were talking early on about the
possibility that if he is able to
conjure
the father back to life for a bit
that the father may say to him you don't
need me to tell you what to do
you can think you you know
form your own conclusions take action
you know that's what real people do you
want to be a person that's the most
important thing
now I don't know if that makes for a
weak robot if it's always
um
dependent on other people telling it
what to do it makes it feel less
sophisticated
but
that might be something that the Sun
imbues the robot with more deeply by
corrupting the operating system to make
it more dependent and more
showing up for orders rather than just
knowing what to do
and feeling more like obeying orders is
a critical part of his correct function
so it's conceivable
so in the healthy aspect a type six the
loyalist is
uh
able to elicit strong emotional
responses from others very appealing
endearing lovable and affectionate but
that's an interesting flavor for an AI
where it really is likable and it's like
hey how you doing a set of greetings you
know it's it could be programmed to be
friendly trust is important bonding with
others forming permanent relationships
and alliances
dedicated to individual and individuals
and movements in which they deeply
believe
um
in the average aspect start investing
their time and energy into whatever they
believe will be safe and stable
organizing and structuring they look to
alliances and authorities for security
and continuity constantly Vigilant
anticipating problems
in the unhealthy aspect fearing they
have ruined their security they become
panicky volatile self-disparaging with
acute inferior inferiority feelings
seeing themselves as defenseless they
seek out a stronger Authority
to or believe to resolve all their
problems
and that's interesting because
in terms of potential crisis
if the sun has been corrupting the
operating system then this thing which
would normally be as confident as Spock
or data like
that's a ridiculous idea here's the
logical thing to do and not going I'm
not sure if that's right like having no
uncertainty at all
the crisis could also consist in Madness
of A Sort where
this formerly supremely confident AI now
has a lot of like self-doubt
because and it's been programmed to seek
advice seek orders
so right at the point when this
automaton needs its own
excellent judgment
at the most critical point in this story
it's faltering in one of the key
I think they nailed it in the book
uh the wisdom of the Enneagram which has
a 40 page chapter on each type instead
of just a one sheet
it says the single most fundamental
weakness of a six is lack of trust in
their own judgment
they just lack of confidence
they're always looking to others tell me
what to do
and so
which is what the sun wants to do to
this row but it wants it to be malleable
and so this
critical failure in
confidence and autonomy and decision
making
at the most critical moment the most
critical juncture in the story
is a great
way to complicate the crisis because
it's not just things are happening
externally which are disastrous and I
gotta leap into action
but
at this point I trust my own as the
robot I trust my own decision making the
least ever
and I'm kind of
incapable of
making a decision and taking an action
at this critical juncture
which is also
makes that decision in action to stand
up
even more dynamic because this robot is
taking a leap of faith or just an a you
know it's one analogy that I use for
decision and action in the face of
crisis
is that
the crisis demands immediate decision
and action
you no longer have the luxury of the
luxury of contemplating your dilemma
from a distance what am I going to do
when I have to choose
so the crisis is akin to like you're
really busy with something in the house
and all caught up in it and you look out
the window and see your kid about to get
hit by a truck on the street
you're not going well I'm in the middle
of this recipe it's like no you're like
throwing the stool right through the
kitchen window and getting cut to crap
to get to the street before your kid
gets flat and like there's the decision
is like instant
and it's like who you really are is
right there
and
that's the nature of decision and action
in the face of Crisis it demands an
immediate decision and action
so for this robot to LEAP into action
even if that's
explosively contrary to some of the
deepest current commands
shows what this robot's really made of
what the true
personality of this what the true
character of this thing is and that's
what Aristotle said decision and action
in the face of Crisis reveal the true
character of the protagonist
and it it can bring out the best in
people
and it can also bring out the worst in
so the person who jumps up and runs out
screaming
or you know somebody doesn't move when
they saw your kid
you know about to get hit they're like
hey you should look out here like why
weren't you out the door before you even
told me you know it's like I thought I
knew you like that's crazy you watched
for three seconds
you know Frozen and I went through the
freaking window while you stood there
doing nothing
people react differently in emergencies
and it strips the mask off and that's
fascinating to the audience
because
in reality we don't often see naked
human emotional reality it's so masked
and covered and camouflaged and
self-deception and rationalizations and
all this stuff that
helps us navigate the world and feel
comfortable but when you strip all that
away and like what are you going to do
right now
some people will run and some people
will leap into action and they don't
they themselves didn't know they were
going to run away or leap into action
you see the people that you know rescued
10 people out of a burning house are
like
I was more surprised than anybody when I
ran in there I didn't think I would ever
do that but I just my legs were running
toward the house when I heard them
screaming
so the Loyalists the type sixes
interested the committed security
oriented type engaging responsible
anxious and suspicious
it's interesting
type 7 the Enthusiast the busy
fun-loving type spontaneous versatile
acquisitive and Scattered basic fear of
being deprived and in pain
basic desire to be satisfied and content
they're highly responsive excitable
enthusiastic about sensation and
experience most extroverted type in the
average aspect as restlessness increases
they want to have more options and
choices available to them less focused
constantly seeking out new things in the
unhealthy aspect desperate to quell
their anxieties can be impulsive and
infantile don't know when to stop so I'm
not sure if that fits anybody except it
might fit the robot as he's in that kind
of giddy phase
always wanting the next distraction but
I'm not sure
type 8 the Challenger the powerful
dominating type self-confident decisive
willful and confrontational basic fear
of being harmed or controlled by others
basic desire to protect themselves to be
in control of their own life and Destiny
and this could easily be the Sun
self-confident self self-assertive
self-confident and strong learn to stand
up for what they need and want
resourceful can-do attitude and
passionate inner Drive decisive and
authoritative
and the average aspect self-sufficiency
Financial Independence and having enough
resources are important concerns
becoming Enterprise pragmatic rugged
individualist Wheeler Dealers
risk-taking hard working
denying on emotional needs and the
unhealthy aspect defying any attempt to
control them become completely ruthless
dictatorial might makes right the
criminal and Outlaw Renegade and con
artist so that could certainly be the
Sun
um
type 3 is interesting for the Sun and
type 8 then there's type 9 The
Peacemaker the easy going self-effacing
type receptive reassuring agreeable and
complacent doesn't really feel like any
of the characters in this story at first
glance
so the robot could be a type 5 or a type
six
and the Sun is definitely a three or an
eight what do you think it could be a
three RNA it really
I mean that's the nature of this game is
that
you it what it did is it gave us several
strong possibilities
two strong possibilities for both the
protagonist and the antagonist
and we don't need to go oh it's that
because what we want to do is navigate
through the story more
and keep in mind that a Type 3 is high
achieving but desperate to look good no
matter what a type 8 is powerful
dominating can make things happen can be
a great leader a healthy eight is
magnanimous generous insightful
giving others credit an unhealthy Aid is
desperate to maintain control
and Crush all opposition
so
they're slightly different
and one may prove more useful as the
story develops more and we may not get
to that point in the development of this
story but that's the process that we're
tentatively holding both of them as
possibilities and seeing which one fits
the demands of the story or if the
Enneagram type suggests possibilities
for the story then we may end up going
with that one
because the Enneagram offers a lot of
specific traits for a character
and it's useful like once you have a
dilemma
tentatively roughed out for the
protagonist which is what we have now
then
it's interesting to look at okay so for
that type of dilemma like I can't let go
of this chance to become a human and
it's like an irrational
it's not just I wish I was a human but
it's like I've got to become human I'm
desperate to get that and I can't
sacrifice people to get there but I
can't let go of that chance so that
particular dilemma you know how does
that go with the type five where the
basic fear is of being useless helpless
or incapable
and they're brilliant and they're always
questioning things and trying to get to
the bottom of things but they're all
constantly model building and
fine-tuning before they take action and
they can be reclusive and isolated from
reality and
get obsessed with dark imagery and so on
so is that
type of dilemma
does a type 5
see
different personality types will
interact with a dilemma in different
ways
like
if you're a Type 3 and you're really
concerned with how you appear to other
people then certain dilemmas will
freak you out more than someone who's
naturally relaxed and
can sweep problems under the carpet like
a type nine
but they're they're relaxed and
comfortable or a type 8 who has to be in
control all the time so
once you get a dilemma up and running
then it's useful to go through the
different Enneagram types and see how
would this type deal with that
particular dilemma
and so
looking at type six
with that dilemma
to be with the basic fear to be without
support or guidance trusting others the
one of the things about a six is they're
they're always hoping that the next
person they link up with will be able to
show them how to really navigate life
properly they attach on to people and go
are you the one that's going to show me
how to really do my life right
so they're always
because they don't trust their own
judgment so you're like you got to tell
me because I can't do it
so with that type of
personality
react
to this dilemma more than a type five
and you know the fact that a type six is
the the
average to unhealthy type the healthy
type six doesn't have that problem
the average to unhealthy type six really
doesn't trust its own inner judgment
because they're very mental they're
they're the top of the thought Triad
there's thought feeling and
I don't remember what the third one is
um
but the type six is the most is the
highest of the thought
Triad in the nine so they're all mental
activity which in the average to
unhealthy aspects means they're out of
touch with their own inner guidance
their heart their gut because they're
always got to think about it but they
can't feel their way through it
which makes them and they know that
they're not good decision makers because
they're not in touch with their
intuition and their internal guidance
system they're cut off from it
so if the Sun is saying
I've made some modifications in you that
get you closer to being a human
than that type six is like this is what
I need especially if the operating
system has been crippled in some ways so
that it's less capable of making
strong fundamental decisions at key
points and is more reliant on the sun
and the Sun is creating great reward
system
and the average type six can become
evasive indecisive cautious
procrastinating and ambivalent
and that's kind of like where the sun
needs him to be
as the sun is trying to manipulate him
into helping sort of go against his own
moral code or against his own
inner programming or
the way he's been programmed
so that's interesting and I would leave
that
we don't need to
solve that at this point
that's something that
you leave those possibilities floating
as the story gets developed further and
one of them will probably like oh this
one is deaf I could see more and more
that it's this one or it may be like we
were wrong on both of them it's really
this but you just have a
a a flexibility a a it's a tentative
answer
and the other thing is that people in
general are often uncomfortable with
partial Solutions
you know like like we're in now where
it's like I'm not really sure but I'm
very used to
making tentative decisions and floating
them both as possibilities as we move
forward just kind of going oh it could
be this or this and time will tell as we
Explore More
but people who are like I don't want to
be halfway through to an answer I don't
like that so then they jump to
conclusions and go okay it's got to be
that and they've cut off they say
experts in creativity know that there's
often 10 right answers to a problem the
people that don't know that when they
find one of the 10 right answers they go
oh that's it but then they stop
questioning and they stop looking and
they're missing on a
the whole spectrum of what is the right
answer and that's what jumping to
conclusions is too you can even be
wildly wrong but you're like I don't
care if I'm wrong I can't I'm desperate
to not be partially formed I can't be
halfway through halfway to a solution